when we write firebase cloud functions
we normally do it in plain JavaScript
but this tends to make them hard to
debug what if we could actually write
them in typescript and also throw on web
pack to make them a little more modular
in this quick lesson I'm going to show
you how to set up your cloud function
environment for typescript and web pack
and then we'll deploy a few cloud
functions to firebase I first want to
point out that there's an article on
medium that was the main inspiration for
this video so I'll add a link to that
the description and if you're brand new
to cloud functions I recommend checking
out any of the blue videos on my channel
which are specifically focused on
firebase cloud functions so to get
started I'm assuming you have an
existing project that you're working on
and you'll bring up the command line and
run firebase and knit functions then
select all the default options during
that project setup this is going to
create a new directory in the root of
the project called functions and that's
an isolated node environment where we
can build our cloud functions so the
next step is to CD into that directory
and then we'll create a new directory
called source and we'll put a file in
there called index TS instead of index j
s then we can go ahead and remove the
index j s file for now web pack will
actually generate the index.js file
automatically based on our underlying
typescript code and that's the file that
actually gets deployed the firebase now
let's open up the package JSON file then
we can install typescript and web pack
and we'll specify them only for that
development environment so your final
node environment should look something
like this
and we can add a TS config file nothing
really special here you can go with the
default options and customize it any way
you want then the last step is to create
the web pack config this will tell web
pack how to compile our type script to a
single index.js file that can be
deployed to firebase check out the link
in the description for more detail on
this code so now we can actually start
building cloud functions we can do this
by creating directories inside the
source directory based on that concerns
that we want to separate in this example
I'm separating my email cloud functions
from my images cloud functions so now we
can start writing cloud functions just
like we normally would
the only differences we can use
typescript and we also use the webpack
import syntax if you've developed
angular apps before this should look
very familiar because it's the exact
approach used by the angular CLI in this
example I just created a couple of cloud
functions that don't do anything named
update image and resize image and just
for this example we'll go ahead and add
one more useless cloud function in that
email directory so now we need to
register these functions in the main
indexed ES file in the source directory
this process is very similar to an NG
module we just import the functions that
we want to deploy and then register that
in this file any constant that's
exported in this file will be picked up
by web pack and that'll be included in
our main index CAS file that gets
deployed so now that we have our
functions defined we can go ahead and
deploy them there's only one extra step
we just have to call the web pack
command which will compile the code into
that index.js file if we check it out we
can see it's mostly a bunch of web pack
code but our actual functions that we
wrote are embedded in there and the
final step is to deploy a firebase by
running firebase deploy only functions
and after a few seconds we should get a
confirmation on the command line and if
we go into the firebase console we
should see these three functions there
as well
overall this gives you a much more easy
to maintain and debug environment for
writing cloud functions that's it for
typescript and firebase cloud functions
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want help building
your own custom cloud functions consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase com
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon
you
[Applause]
[Music]